this weekend has been jam-packed with
sports concerts and
entertainment really all across the
valley thanks so much for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock
i'm sasha loftis we also saw those
record-breaking temperatures here in las
vegas but
that didn't stop many from coming out to
experience everything
madison kimbrough is on the las vegas
strip tonight she joins us live to break
it all down
madison this is the summer of
entertainment revival so many names so
many shows so many activities here
in the entertainment capital of the
world take a look
[Music]
this summer is heating up in lots of
ways and we're not just talking about
the temperature
for starters tonight is big on the
entertainment front as allegiant stadium
hosts its first ever country music
concert
with country legend garth brooks taking
center stage for the first time in over
a year
tonight's fight at ufc 264 with conor
mcgregor and dustin poirier drew in tons
of people
including former president donald trump
now even though mcgregor lost
lots of people were betting on him to
take it all the way we're putting on
mcgregor
for them to go all the five rounds it's
crazy
they just like pull on fight each other
and
like they just go at it bruno mars also
kicked off his las vegas residency at
park mgm last weekend
tonight's show marks his fourth on the
tour right now dj zed
performed at resorts world tonight an
english electronic music duo disclosure
will be performing tomorrow night
visitors on the strip are excited for
these events but are still hesitant to
be around
so many people coveted heard them so bad
that they got to bring all this
all these events in right now to build
the city back up
las vegas is back open for business they
call it sin city i call it salvation
city
i feel some apprehension about the fact
that everyone's out here without a mask
and like packing close together
but on the flip side i'm also like super
excited because it's been so long
and we can't forget usher pop and r b
artist one of my favorites to
begin with obviously he's going to take
place this friday at caesars palace
his first las vegas residency so look
out for that as for a full recap of the
fight we'll have that coming up later in
sports
reporting live from the strip madison
kimbrough 8 news now